واتفاق من مخاطر الهجمات الالكترونيه في
العالم اولى منتدى ضابط اهتماما بالغا
بالامن السيبراني والتصدي لمحاولات الهجوم
على البنوك تحتيه وسرقه البيانات وعرقله
العمليات الامنيه المشاركون حذرون من ان
عدم الاستقرار الجيو السياسي يفاقم مخاطر
الهجمات الالكترونيه وبالتالي يؤثر على
قرارات الشركات والمستثمرين وبين ما تزيد
قدرته المجرمين السبرانيين تطورا لفت
المشاركون في دابوس الى افتقار الحكومات
والقطاع الخاص الى خبراء امن البنا
التحتيه الرقميه وشح المهارات
وفي تقرير توقعات الامن السيبراني العالمي
لعام 2023 الذي اصدره المنتدى يرجح خبراء
الامن السيبراني احتماله وقوع حدث
سيبرانيا كارثيه في العامين المقبلين وقد
شهدت الاشهر الماضيه عدد من الهجمات
السبرانيه حول العالم كذلك التي عرفلت
خدمه البريد في المملكه المتحده لمده
اسبوعين واخرى استهدفت مستشفيات على نطاق
الواسع في الولايات المتحده وهجمات كتفت
الضغوط العسكريه على اوكرانيا التقرير
الخاصه الى ان السبيل الامثل لمواجهه
التهديدات السبرانيه هو الاستثمار
التقنيات الجديده وتسخير الذكاء الاصطناعي
في التصدي للاجراميه للاضافه الى سرعه
انتاج التقنيه الجديده اللازمه